[Music]
all right well thank you for being here
I'm excited
about our studio konnekt I want to talk
to you a little bit about where the
products been I'm gonna unveil a few
things that we've been working on in
recent months today and then I want to
talk to you about where we're going in
the future but I'm gonna do this through
a vehicle that's a little bit unorthodox
so just between us and this doesn't
leave this room I've been working on a
little side hustle called
hats for cats taught me this is outside
of my role at our studio and basically
hats for cats is all about addressing
the booming market of cat owners who
need head bare for their pets and so one
of the things that we've been trying to
work on here we've raced around funding
hired a data science team and I kind of
got a front row seat to sort of our
experience using our there and sort of
what that looked like and so I thought
I'd share that with you today and see if
any of that resonates with with kind of
how your journey so things start about
really great right everyone was in our
we had two data scientists originally
they were both using our and they both
installed our just you know recently
when they got started they're using the
latest versions of our packages and
everything was just fine there were only
a handful of artifacts that they
produced so they had a couple hour
markdown reports we had one shiny app
everybody knew where everything was and
so there wasn't really any ambiguity and
we're all using the latest versions of
everything into it so everything just
worked out fine but pretty quickly
things went downhill so after about four
or five months we had enough content now
that people started getting confused
about where is this report live where
does this shiny out live and our data
scientists were spending all their days
not actually doing data science but
answering these requests about can you
send me this report can you rerun this
report to get this week's data or you
know can you run this report just for my
product right and so they spend all
their time doing these mini lasts
instead of doing the stuff that we
really want them to do which is
unlocking value by tapping into and
exploring the data that we have secondly
it was it was all irreproducible so we
started having problems where one
analyst would send the other analyst
encode and they weren't able to run it
successfully or they would go to rerun
something that they'd run six months ago
and all of a sudden nothing works
because some package changed and so
they'd spend all day fixing this thing
that should have taken five minutes and
the content is spread all over so we
have dozens of reports now they're on
our network share they're on slack there
you know tricking Lee around an email
and nobody knows where anything is which
creates a huge problem and then lastly
we had some issues with security right
we had at a couple of occasions we had
some sensitive financial reports that
ended up on a network share that were
accessible to the whole company which
which nobody wants but we solve these
problems with our studio konnekt and so
I'll talk to you a little bit about that
if you're unfamiliar our studio konnekt
is a Content hub and execution engine
for your data products and so what that
specifically means as an analyst is that
your first experience is going to be
clicking a little publish button in the
our Studio IDE which I'll show you and
that will do all the hard work of
getting your content from your computer
onto the remote machine you can schedule
and distribute our markdown content and
so now you get kind of an easier way to
be able to operationalize some of the
content deep reduce you can handle the
kind of scaling problems that we've been
discussing about all morning around
shiny applications to be able to send
you know more and more traffic towards
Chiney or polymer AP is that you've
deployed and one of the more important
features you can manage access controls
and so you can actually go in and say
these users at these groups should be
able to access the you know this report
but nobody else is gonna be able to see
it and an important caveat this is an
on-premises commercial application so
this is not one of our open source
contributions but this is something that
you can purchase and run inside your
firewall on premises and so this will
integrate with your directory of users
and groups and all that kind of stuff so
a couple things that I'm excited to
announce today that are available in the
ones haveno release first of all spur
grammatic deployment and so most people
tend to reach for the push button
deployment from the our studio IDE but
you also have the option now of saying
if you want to point your Jenkins or
your bamboo server at a git repo and
have it monitor that and automatically
pull down changes and publish those you
now have that option with the
programmatic deployment we have
customizable email if you haven't seen
this yet so you can go in and you can
tailor like the body of an email or the
the message as we've said this morning
and I'll lastly be a Content
instrumentation or metrics around your
content so you can see who's viewing
your content win and then you can go in
and kind of use that data to develop
reports or answer questions like what
what is the most important content what
should I be maintaining where should I
be putting my energy so let me show you
a quick demo
what that looks like so let's actually
start in the our Studio IDE and what I
have here is just a kind of
run-of-the-mill hour markdown report so
I can knit this locally and the original
workflow that our data scientists were
using is that they would do some
analysis and then they would you know
render it locally on their desktop and
then they'd go in and say you know for
this week sales we're gonna copy this
image out into an email or copy it into
a PowerPoint and send that over to our
executives so it's a lot of kind of
manually you know operating on this data
and they spend a lot of their time just
kind of hand crafting these reports
rewriting these things every day so the
better alternative that I'll suggest
today is you click this publish button
here and that allows you to send up the
relevant files that you're working with
any data that you're using locally and
you can publish that over to our studio
konnekt and what's gonna happen behind
the scenes is it's gonna capture all of
the code that you're using in this
report and then additionally it's going
to build a manifest of all the packages
that you're using and even the versions
of those are packages and so now you get
all of that that's happening here and
then that's gonna get recreated
identically on the server and so now you
have no kind of lack of parity between
your local experience and what's going
to run on the server and so lo and
behold I now have this our studio
Connect report that has that looks just
like what it looked like on my desktop
and is using the same packages the same
version of our etc now what's exciting
about this is that now I have a URL that
I can use to just send other
collaborators and they can now see the
same report without any work on their
heart or any installing of software or
anything like that
secondly you've got these access
controls over here so I can now lock
down who should be able to view this
report maybe it's just me maybe I want
to make it public or maybe everybody in
the organization should be able to see
it and then because it's in our markdown
report I can also schedule this to
repeat and so maybe I want this report
to run every week let's say I wanted to
run every Monday morning and then
perhaps even send an email out once it's
done to be executives who would you know
or who are interested in this report and
so all that now it's gonna happen for
free and what's great is that if there's
ever a problem with this report if
there's an issue running it I'm gonna
get an email saying hey your report had
a problem you should go check it out and
so now I don't have to think about this
anymore and I can just schedule this
report once and then leave it running so
this is pretty exciting but we can
go one step further and so tarrif
alluded to a concept this morning called
parameterised our markdown and I'm
curious how many of you have used
parameter I start markdown yet
okay so decent number of you so
parameterised our markdown it's actually
a concept that you can use locally and
so I'd encourage you all to try this
it's a pretty handy way to just kind of
define a set of parameters that you want
to put into an our markdown report and
then you can actually just go through
and leverage those parameters to to kind
of tailor the report to the experience
that you want and so within the IDE you
just click this knit with parameters
button and now I can go in and I can say
rather than just running a weekly report
maybe I want to run a report for a
particular product in our line or a
different number of days for you know
the historical data and now I can go
through and knit that and then I just
get the local report here that has the
data that I want so this would be at
least a step up for you if you have
people coming back and repeatedly saying
I want this report but slightly modified
this gives you a way to handle one
source code one you know bit of one
report that you need to maintain but you
know still be able to create things for
your users that they're interested in
but even better if you deploy this on
our studio konnekt you actually get this
little input tab on the left and that
allows other users who have an installed
are who have an installer studio who are
not scientists to go in and be able to
specify those parameters themselves and
so now I can say that same report for 30
days cowboy hat I can run that report
and I can just get the data that I'm
interested in even better this is a
full-fledged report on connect and so I
can kind of pop around and view
different reports here that I've you
know previously configured and saved and
then if I want to schedule these or even
distribute these automatically I can do
that and so now I have one one our
markdown document that I'm maintaining
one bit of source code that I've worked
on and yet all these people are able to
kind of get the customized tailored
views that they're interested in but
they can even define themselves without
me having to be involved at all
so this is a huge step up and then
connect also can support your shiny
applications and your print your API
plumber ApS so this I usually wouldn't
show sensitive financial data at my
company here but oh I think real friends
I'll show this to you so you can go back
and you know this is a little dashboard
that we would share you know internally
we've got a big monitor in our office
that kind of shows
and I think there might be a bug or
something in this report but we've got
you know basically you can kind of see
how the company is doing and you know
how things how things look so you've got
all the normal toggles that you want
with shiny to be able to host that and
let people interact with it again the
same access controls everything that
you'd want there but even better with
shiny now I can go in and I can scale
out processes to you know handle the
capacity that I'm expecting or even as
Joe was alluding to earlier we can also
handle clustered environments for a
studio konnekt so if you were here last
year you might have seen Shawn lop give
the demonstration of having 10,000
concurrent users on a shiny application
using our studio konnekt so there's
really you know you can handle pretty
you know broad scale of incoming content
here and then lastly we have the same
thing our own plumber API is if you're
using plumber that we can easily host
those and you get all the same scaling
and tuning parameters that you'd expect
with shiny to be able to define you know
how responsive you need this to be and
kind of you know what sort of load you
would expect all right so let's hop back
to the slides so that's really
everything that I want to show you
around our but there's one more topic
that I want to address before in our
time together and that is Python so this
has come up already a couple times in
this track but one of the things that we
did it hats for cats is we hired a data
analyst that was using Python and so
historically it was pretty difficult to
integrate together right you've kind of
got these two different languages that
they don't owner operate all that well
this has improved a lot recently with
the reticulate package and so if you
haven't seen this reticulate is a way
for you to invoke and interact with your
Python code using our and so this got a
lot better and we were kind of able to
find some ways to work together but
there was still this open question of
what are we going to do when it comes
time to publish so we had this great
publishing and operationally
operationalization system for our
content and our studio konnekt that we
lacked with Python and so I'm excited to
announce today we now have Python
support in our studio konnekt
so specifically this looks like two
different features so first of all you
have what Teresa this morning which is
our s connect and the art the our Studio
IDE now capture the Python dependencies
in the Python packages that you have
locally before you deploy so if you are
using reticulate in your our content and
you go to publish you'll get the same
experience with your Python packages
that you're used to with your our
packages but even more exciting in my
opinion is we now have a jupiter
notebook plugin which allows you to
publish directly from your jupiter
notebooks you get the exact same push
button publishing experience that you
have in the art studio ide with your art
content you now have in jupiter
notebooks with python so i'll show you
this from a quick so the motivating
feature here is in hats for cats a lot
of our customers would say look I know
what your hat looks like I can see that
picture online and I know what my cat
looks like but I can't always envision
what they would look like together and
so we wanted to do some some engineering
to solve this problem so first of all we
hopped into a jupiter notebook and we
did some exploration to say you know how
effective can we be at detecting faces
you know in a given image and so this is
a jupiter notebook that i have here
which you know our Jupiter or our Python
analyst produced using all Python code
and I click this publish button in the
Jupiter notebook and I get that same
experience of being able to send this
code over into our studio konnekt and
you'll see that it's doing all the same
kind of intelligent features that we had
in our around looking at the version of
Python that we're using the versions of
the different packages and then it sends
it up to connect and now I click this
button and I can see as you can see I
didn't have it rendered locally but this
actually rendered on the server until
you get kind of you know the full
abilities of your server here and that
entire environment was recreated so that
I get the exact same experience locally
as I get remotely and then you get all
the same bells and whistles that you
have with our markdown content in terms
of being able to schedule this rerun it
email it etc one other feature then
around Python is if you wanted to use
this in a reticulated way then you can
do that as well and so we have the
stupider notebook we've proven that we
have kind of a validation of our
technology and so now we know okay we
can detect faces effectively but one of
the things that we now want to do is we
want to operationalize this and we have
we
you know a great ability to do that with
an R as you've seen through plumber or
through shiny there are a lot of great
ways for you to take your R code and get
it into the hands of your users and so
one of the things we wanted to do was
actually build a shiny app that uses the
Python code on the backend to do the
image detection so Python has some
really strong image processing libraries
it specifically OpenCV and so we wanted
to continue using Python for what Python
it's good for but use R for what R is
good for and so develop a shiny
application that allows us to kind of
blend those two and so here we put
together just kind of a preview of what
that's gonna look like that we can host
on our page so this is a shiny
application with a little webcam widget
input and now I can envision what it's
going to look like for me to purchase
any of these different hats for my cat I
unfortunately don't have a cat up here
with me so you'll have to use your
imagination but right so now you get the
same capabilities that you would expect
around being able operationalize your
content whether or not it's using Python
under the hood all right so a little bit
about what's next one of the things that
we're working on is called sam'l if you
don't know what that means just skip it
but if you do that might excite you this
is a new way to kind of authenticate
users into an organization that your IT
people may be excited about we're also
working on the job launcher integration
so you've probably heard a couple of
references to this but the basic premise
is that we want to be able to run our in
other environments rather than just the
local server where connect is installed
so if you're using kubernetes or if
you're using slurm or some other kind of
compute bucket we'll be able to
distribute our our processes there so
that you can see them and run them there
we're also working on formal git
integration so being able to use git
kind of as a first-class citizen within
connect so that you point at a github
repository we'll manage or we'll monitor
that repository for changes pull down
any changes that come in and
automatically deploy it you also get an
improved view of scheduled content and
so you can see what processes are
scheduled to run when and who's
scheduled you know what kind of work to
run you can get customizable views into
content so we've heard from a lot of
people especially like consultants who
say I want to kind of branded portal for
the for my customers I don't want to
show your logos I want to show my logo
and so being able to kind of do that in
a way that allows people to sort of
tailor the different views that they get
and the different experiences there's
more of kind of a content management
system and then lastly more connect
server
API endpoints and so as if you've been
paying attention lately you've seen more
and more of these API endpoints that we
put out to allow people to control
connect as kind of a black box rather
than just you know interactive usage and
you can see a couple little previews on
the right here of some of the things
that we're working on so first of all
kind of an expanded view and this sort
of plays into some of the work that
we're gonna be doing around content
management and then also down at the
bottom you can see a little bit of eye
candy that we're gonna put together
around some of the metrics and
instrumentation data that we have so
that you can see there are the different
ways that people are using your content
and kind of how popular it is and since
I have one minute I will show you one
other feature that I forgot to show you
earlier which is one of the features
that reef showcased a little bit this
morning was the ability to go in and
customize your emails programmatically I
wanted to drill into that just a little
bit which is so right now we've got this
single rendered view of my content that
just you know in general when you put in
our markdown document together it's
gonna render to an HTML or to a PDF so
you get that same experience here in
connect but we also have some
conventions defined by which you can say
you know what I actually want to tailor
the email message that's gonna go out
associated with this email and so now
when I go to distribute this report I'm
gonna email this just to myself and when
I go look at my email inbox as soon as
that report is done generating then I'm
gonna get an email and you can see
already first of all that we've got a
customized subject line this is tailored
to the report that just ran I've got 142
sales this past week and then you can
see that I've got this pros it doesn't
look exactly like what I had in my
remark done report that I rendered this
is a different view and so I've got this
code and you know with graphs embedded I
can kind of define these tables that are
customized and this is all leveraging
the blastula package under the hood but
now what I can do is rather than you
know relying on connectors to kind of
attach an HTML file to an email and my
executives are going to open instead I
can actually tailor it so that exactly
what I want them to receive is gonna lay
them in their inbox they can look at
this on their phone on the way into the
office and even customizing the
attachments so here I generate an excel
file and I've attached that so that if
somebody wants to actually download and
peruse the data they can do so
themselves all right and so that is
everything that I've got for you if
you're interested in connect I'd
encourage you to visit this link up top
and that will get you a 45 day free
trial for kynect so you can download
that and start playing with it we'd love
to get your feedback we're gonna be
hanging out at the publish booth out in
the prologue and so if there are
features either that you're excited
about or features that we lack that are
kind of deal-breakers for you I'd
especially love to hear about those so
please come talk to us and the slides in
code are all available at that link
there in the middle with that I've got
time for a few questions thanks Jeff
yeah we've got time for a couple of
questions we'll throw those mics around
a quick question on the parametrize
reports is there any way to in the
future programmatically schedule those
because I couldn't imagine having a
bunch of parameters going to generate a
bunch of reports how do we yeah yeah we
definitely like to do that so I found
that under the category of more connect
server API endpoints but that's one of
the things that we want to do is allow
people to more efficiently kind of
invoke you know executions of reports or
even tailor kind of the parameters that
they want to book them with so yeah
that'll definitely come soon Connect
makes it easy to change read access to
the reports like the our markdown can it
be used for collaboration purposes to to
manage the write permissions on that
yeah yeah yeah so I can acquire that but
let me see that real quick so inside of
connect what you can do is you can go
into any report here and you can manage
viewership permissions and also
collaborator permissions and so I can go
in and I can add some user that's inside
my organization and I can you know add
them as a collaborator under the
document so that they would then be able
to publish a distant point as well
sorry everything would be hosted on the
server yeah yeah so typically they would
you would usually get to organize your
you know your collaboration locally and
then somebody's going to publish at some
point you could use the programmatic
deployment or one of you could push
button publish if you wanted and you
would not also have Dave sand version
control yeah so we don't have that built
into the product but we would encourage
you to use something like it to be able
to track some of that you do have access
to those different source versions that
have been deployed so you could go back
and grab the bundle that was deployed
previously but it's not going to show
you like a dish for a commit message
necessarily without a question right
over here so three quick questions one
for the usage monitoring or people
accessing the resources are they is
there support or interacting with the
underlying data and maybe plugging it
into other organizational and data that
that might be available to people with
the apps that's one question the other
question is for apps that are published
shiny apps that are published is there
any support for updating users who might
be looking at an app that a new version
is available or just best for an
individual app or just across the board
if you want to mention that you're
updating the server and it's gonna be
down or something like that you can't
tell everyone yes
we don't have a way to proactively reach
out to users have a particular
application know that you could use the
instrumentation to pull down all the
users that have visited it in the past
30 days or something and notify them
that way if you wanted to we do have
options within the server to be able to
define kind of like right up here you
could put like a little warning box just
to kind of alert your users that hey we
have scheduled you know maintenance for
during this window or something so you'd
be able to do that and for the kind of
the first part of the question I'm not
sure if I totally understand but were
you referring to the server metrics like
so here we have CPU and RAM and things
like that or are you referring to data
that's inside your report oh so it's not
on a user specific user name basis
correct okay yeah yeah so we don't have
yeah resource monitoring at the user
level just yet but we do have some some
little visibility here that you can use
to kind of you know envision that here
on your admin page and then we also do
support exporting this to a graphite
system which may be something that you
write
they do a lot of this racing that there
are future plans for maybe having user
specific usage yeah yeah so I think you
know what we want to do is you know give
you at least better insight into what's
gonna be running and when and then kind
of you know sort of a static view into
all right at this moment you know who's
using the most memory who's using the
most CPU and be able to kind of turn
that and so yeah I don't think it's out
of reach that we would have historical
views on that to you but okay yeah and
then the instrumentation is also
available there to see like who's
consuming the content
[Music]